[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et pour commenter cette
semaine sous haute tension notre invité
Sylvain Maillard bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député renaissance de Paris
vice-président du groupe Renaissance on
va bien évidemment parler du sujet de
marin les retraites et oui la première
ministre Elisabeth borne a décidé jeudi
de passer en force la réforme des
retraites à l'Assemblée nationale en
déclenchant l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution faute d'une majorité
certaine sur ce texte l'opposition a
donc décidé de déposer une motion de
censure du gouvernement en texte
transpartisan qui sera disputé lundi et
pourtant malgré l'utilisation du 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat avait
adopté le texte final de la réforme des
retraites fruits d'un compromis entre
les 7 députés et sept sénateurs de la
commission mixte paritaire
c'est donc l'épilogue d'une longue
séquence politique et parlementaire
débuter il est à peu près deux mois ce
jeudi 16 mars à 15h Elisabeth borne a
donc décidé de recourir à l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution pour faire
passer la réforme des retraites sous les
huets regardez ce compte rendu de séance
surréaliste réalisé par Marion Becker la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
c'est saouler huer des oppositions sous
les paroles de la Marseillaise anthonée
par les groupes de gauche
[Applaudissements]
et les claquements de pupitre du
rassemblement national kelisabeth borne
prend la parole c'est sûr votre réforme
sur le texte du Parlement fruit d'un
compromis entre les deux assemblées que
je suis prête à engager ma
responsabilité et dans ce tumulte la
première ministre annonce le recours en
49,3 aussi
de 4 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 une
issue sans surprise et pourtant amer
pour les alliés de la majorité on est
déçu parce qu'on voulait aller au vote
on voulait aller au vote on voulait que
que la représentation nationale puisse
s'exprimer et que chacun aussi prenne
ses responsabilités j'en veux énormément
républicain parce que ceux à quoi on
vient d'assister c'est un simulacre
c'est un simulacre de démocratie ces
gens-là préfèrent le 49-3 parce qu'ils
n'auront pas besoin de d'exprimer leur
vote et comme ça ils sauvent ceux qui
sont contre alors qu'ils ont pendant
deux présidentielles soutenus la
retraite à 65 ans un rôle que refuse
d'endosser les républicains qui
regardent d'abord devant leur porte qui
balaye d'abord leur perron parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est juste inadmissible
de nous faire porter le chapeau alors
qu'au sein même de leur groupe
Renaissance horizon modem il y avait les
défaillances et donc il faut d'abord se
mêler de ses des affaires avant de venir
chercher des poux dans les parties
d'opposition pour la France insoumise ce
49-3 signes l'échec du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron le combat est loin
d'être fini et je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui que nous sommes dans un
basculement autoritaire aujourd'hui
comment le premier jour du reste du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron de la fin
du quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron un
échec c'est aussi ce que dit le Front
national c'est incontestablement une
dénaturation de notre fonctionnement
démocratique pour faire passer une
réforme dont chacun admet qu'elle est
brutale injuste
inefficace
injuste et injustifiée d'ailleurs donc
je pense que Madame borne doit partir
prochaine étape l'émotion de censure
annoncée par les oppositions
alors Sylvain Maillard peut avant cette
décision beaucoup beaucoup dans votre
groupe appelé à un vote un vote et
finalement 49-3 c'est un coup de force
démocratique un délit de
depuis des semaines nous avons toujours
dit que nous voulions voter c'est mon
groupe
derrière Aurore berger notre présidente
avait déjà dit publiquement son souhait
nous avions dit les uns et les autres
les paroles le souhait du groupe
extrêmement majoritairement d'aller au
vote donc c'est une grosse déception le
matin donc ce jeudi matin nous avons
refait les comptes avec d'ailleurs les
dirigeants et des du groupe LR alexiotti
Olivier Marleix et il nous manquait des
voix des députés LR qui se sont fait
élire il y a encore 6 mois 9 mois sur le
projet à 65 ans
ont décidé de d'être populaire on renie
leur histoire on renie leur promesse au
fond on était dans une
probablement une un à un ou deux votes
près dans le risque de ne pas faire
passer cette réforme qui est
indispensable et donc moi je encore une
fois je vois la différence je vois que
LR n'est plus dirigée en réalité il y a
des groupes LR à l'intérieur de
l'auto-entrepreneuriat avec une partie
de l'air qui est fidèle à son histoire
qui a tenu la barre je dois le saluer et
une autre partie DLR qui a totalement
tourné le dos qui sont devenus des
baronnies locales et qui veulent qu'une
seule chose être populaire mais du coup
même avec cette majorité incertaine
est-ce qu'il fallait utiliser le 49-3
notamment dans le contexte où une
majorité de Français est opposée à la
réforme et ce qu'il ne fallait pas quand
même prendre le risque du vote la
responsabilité c'est de faire un choix
le choix il est très tout le monde
savait que nous voulions aller au vote
la responsabilité est-ce qu'il faut
cette réforme pour la France oui ou non
c'est ça la question qui a été posée à
la première ministre et au président de
la République en responsabilité ils ont
choisi en disant il est essentiel que
cette réforme passe pour sécuriser nos
pensions assurer un niveau des
cotisations et des pensions qui soient
payées dans les années qui viennent
faire en sorte qu'on puisse sécuriser
nos retraités c'est ça qui a été choisi
alors oui c'est un populaire ça c'est
certain une réforme des retraites c'est
toujours un populaire mais nous sommes
face aussi quelque part ils sont face à
l'Histoire il nous faut assurer le
système de retraite dans les années qui
viennent on parle de crise de régime de
crise sociale politique qui risque de
s'aggraver est-ce que vous admettez tout
ça est-ce que vous redoutez une
paralysie dès à présent du quinquennat
de la suite nous sommes dans une
situation qui n'est pas évidente je le
conçois en même temps ce sont les outils
démocratiques des outils qui existent le
49-3 a toujours existé nous l'utilisons
parce que c'est important c'est
essentiel que cette réforme puisse se
mettre en oeuvre je rappelle que ça veut
dire que dès cette année on va pouvoir
commencer à revaloriser les petites
pensions dès cette année je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
retraités qui attendaient ça aussi c'est
aussi ça que qui se jouait c'est pas
uniquement des lois en chambre c'est
concrètement comment on change la vie
d'opensionner et grâce à cette loi grâce
au
travail qu'on a pu faire en CMP on va je
pense y revenir on a pu trouver une
commission mix paritaire
on a dû travailler toute une journée
très concrètement comment faire pour
améliorer le texte parce que le texte
qui a présenté Elisabeth borne au mois
de janvier et le texte qui a été qui est
à l'heure actuelle passée en 49-3 c'est
pas tout à fait le même on a beaucoup
beaucoup amélioré le texte donc pour
vous le 49-3 est un outil démocratique
il est constitutionnel dans ce contexte
selon vous les démocraties c'est un
outil démocratique comme vous savez moi
je je je je prends un peu de recul nous
avons été élu
les députés les sénateurs sont élus
démocratiquement ils représentent ils
ont le l'autorité pour faire des choix
les choix politiques et ils les assume
devant leurs électeurs la rue elle a une
légitimité
je vais aller jusqu'au bout elle a la
légitimité et de n'a pas la légitimité
qu'on les représentants la nation donc
je pense qu'il faut pas tout mettre dans
dans un autre sort d'amalgame oui il y a
une difficulté je voulais je vous l'ai
dit je l'ai dit de façon de très clair
clairement mais l'essentiel pour nous
pour le pays c'est de passer cette
réforme c'est important et donc nous
utilisons les outils démocratiques qui
existent il y a pas de coup de force il
y a juste une utilisation des outils
démocratiques Emmanuel Macron a invoqué
des risques financiers trop grands pour
se passer de cette réforme est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'il fallait quelque part
aussi rassurer les marchés financiers
qui prêtent à la France mais vous savez
dans tous les journaux vous commencez en
disant tel ou tel banque est en
difficultés on a des taux d'intérêt et
qui ont beaucoup augmenté de ces
derniers mois vous savez c'est les taux
d'intérêt qui augmentent c'est pour la
France entre 11 et 13 milliards cette
année qui partent comme ça 11 et 13
milliards c'est énorme d'ailleurs ça
correspond au déficit qu'on attend
pratiquement année après année jusqu'en
2030 pour les retraites ça part comme ça
la donne a changé la donne a changé
depuis quelques mois il nous faut nous
adapter il faut sécuriser les pensions
de nos retraités être sûr qu'ils ne vont
pas baisser dans le temps et donc les
cotisations doivent payer les pensions
c'est ça le système par répartition nous
l'assumons nous y comprenons que c'est
un paupière vous savez quoi dans
quelques années comme la réforme verte
comme les réformes touraines on nous
dira c'était nécessaire il fallait les
faire elles sont difficiles parfois mais
majorité et puis il y avait une crise
financière il y avait aussi une majorité
de Français qui était contre et il y a
eu aussi des manifestations je les
oublie pas alors Sylvain Mayer une
motion de censure du gouvernement
transpartisanes va être déposé par
l'opposition
discuter lundi vous craignez quelle soit
votée ce sera le vote ce sera là le vote
pour la réforme des retraites chacun
devra se positionner y compris chez LR
a priori il n'y a pas de il y a pas de
majorité en tout cas de ce que nous
voyons il n'y a pas de majorité parce
que il y a quand même une sorte de
responsabilité au dernier moment qui
arrive entre autres chez certains
républicains je crois que ils savent au
fond ils l'ont défendu pendant tellement
d'années pour vous si on est si on vote
pour la censure pour vous ça veut dire
qu'on te fait c'est-à-dire là on vote
contre la réforme des retraites très
clairement sur votre ascension
le gouvernement s'est engagé dessus la
première minute c'est pas la même chose
de rejeter une réforme des retraites et
de censurer le gouvernement notamment
quand on est député là écoutez là à
l'heure actuelle comme la présenter la
première ministre c'est un pour eux
contre la réforme des retraites on est
dans un moment politique extrêmement
fort avec
des Français une rue qu'encore mobilisés
même s'il y a moins de monde dans la rue
on l'a très bien compris ce sera pour ou
contre l'antenne d'ailleurs vous l'avez
dit c'est le groupe liotte donc qui est
un groupe indépendant qui porte donc
c'est d'autant plus
ça imprimera le ou contre la réforme des
retraites la perspective tout de même
parce que de l'utilisation de ce 49-3
risque quand même de de conduire à une
radicalisation du mouvement syndical qui
se présente sous un sous une bannière
unique est-ce que vous craignez un
embrasement du pays j'appelle la
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales qui ont été extrêmement
dignes qui ont manifesté partout en
France quand elles organisaient les
manifestations dans le calme et je veux
vraiment le saluer nous on a continué à
discuter avec les organisations
syndicales d'un point de vue local
l'ensemble des députés Renaissance
continuer à tenir langue avec nos
contacts locaux
départementaux régionaux nationaux pour
certains d'entre nous pour continuer
parce qu'il y aura une vie d'après il y
aura un texte une loi travail parce que
ce que nous avons entendu nous dans la
rue certains évidemment disent c'est les
64 ans peut-être c'est ce qu'il y a
évidemment cimenté mais c'est aussi nous
on veut travailler mieux et donc comment
on va faire pour adapter le travail pour
que plus de Français et envie de
travailler c'est se sentent mieux au
travail ne le voit pas comme comme on a
pu l'entendre sur les bancs de la nups
c'est-à-dire 2 ans de prison on prend
deux enfermes donc c'est là où on voit
qu'il y a un vrai une vraie
accompagnement un vrai un vrai réflexion
à faire Olivier du socle portant une loi
travail dans quelques semaines et ce qui
à partir de maintenant Emmanuel Macron
doit parler avec les syndicats alors que
normalement et bien la mobilisation
contre cette réforme de retraite va être
relancée par ce 49-3 vous savez la
discussion avec les syndicats elle a
jamais été coupée mais mais qu'on soit
clair les syndicats d'ailleurs beaucoup
de réformes que nous que nous avons
porté entre autres et voté dans la
commission mixparita sont portées entre
autres par la CFDT qui refuse la
paternité ou n'en parle pas en tout cas
d'autres l'index c'est le senior mais il
y a un point dur et nous l'ont toujours
dit c'est les 64 ans donc on peut parler
on continue à parler mais ils nous
disent une seule chose tant que vous ne
retirez pas ça il ne se passe rien on ne
veut même pas discuter du reste alors
que cette loi la loi améliore c'est vrai
demande un effort supplémentaire aux
Français pour ceux qui le peuvent de
travailler deux ans de plus mais tout le
reste c'est que de l'amélioration du
système à l'heure actuelle que de
l'amélioration du 6 milliards justement
on va parler du fond de ce texte final
de la réforme de retraite qui a quand
même été adopté par le Sénat jeudi matin
un texte final qui a été le fruit d'un
compromis entre les sept députés et sept
sénateurs de la commission mixte
paritaire les explications de Jérôme
Rabier au moment de valider le texte
issu de la commission mixte paritaire à
la Chambre haute la rapporteur général
Elisabeth Doisneau n'a pas fait mystère
qu'elle considérait ce texte comme une
victoire des arguments de longue date de
la majorité sénatoriale vous retrouverez
dans le texte qui vous est présenté les
principales mesures que nous avons
examinées
et adopter tout au long de la semaine
dernière et même pour certaines depuis
plusieurs années dans le cadre des PLFSS
c'est donc logiquement que le vote a été
largement favorable à cette version
issue de la CMP avec 183 voix pour et
114 contre et même le ministre a défendu
les ajouts de la droite à l'issue de ce
vote ce texte a été amélioré amélioré
par le débat parlementaire avec une
mesure favorable aux femmes qui ont une
carrière complète avec une meilleure
prise en compte de la pénibilité des
carrières longues avec de nombreux
amendements issus de la majorité comme
des oppositions qui permettent de
renforcer les droits de faciliter la vie
des assurés et d'aller vers un système
de retraite qui soit à la fois équilibré
c'est notre objectif premier et amélioré
au moment de voir qui a le plus pesé
dans les débats l'un des artisans de
cette réforme version sénatoriale le
sénateur René Paul Savary était plus que
satisfait des mesures conservées un
mixte à la fois de volonté exprimée à
l'Assemblée nation au final à travers
notamment les carrières longues pour
lequel il était nécessaire d'avoir une
durée de cotisation appropriée et puis
côté Sénat nous avions travaillé à la
fois sur les droits familiaux sur
l'usure professionnelle sur
l'employabilité des seniors à travers le
CD seniors et nous avons obtenu
satisfaction de ce côté-là à gauche en
revanche la pilule est amère avec bien
peu d'amendements conservés de leur côté
le gouvernement a lâché beaucoup de
choses pour s'assurer du vote des
républicains et tout cela sur le dos des
salariés parce que l'objectif de la CMP
ça n'était pas comment dire d'adoucir le
projet de loi c'était de d'éviter au
gouvernement et au président de la
République de perdre la face un texte de
compromis entre la droite et le
gouvernement voté au Sénat mais qui
n'aura pas suffi à trouver une majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale Sylvain Maillard
sur le fond malgré ses améliorations
apportées par la négociation entre le
Sénat et le gouvernement
manquer à ce texte pour qu'il soit
accepté par une plus grande majorité de
députés et de français c'est très
difficile de porter une réforme des
retraites je vous dis ça fait la seconde
j'ai commencé en 2017 à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la seconde réforme que
nous portions on a eu une autre réforme
portée avec Edouard Philippe c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que en
réalité ce sont des sujets très
techniques les retraites c'est 42
régimes différents avec des spécificités
c'est extrêmement technique d'ailleurs
je voudrais saluer nos rapporteurs
Stéphanie iris pour l'Assemblée
nationale et Madame douanneau est la
sénatrice Doisneau et le rapporteur
Savary pour la d'abord le travail en
commun ce qu'on a pu aboutir mais aussi
leurs connaissances et ce qu'ils ont pu
apporter au débat en CMP qui a été très
très je dirais calme et constructive on
a passé une journée c'est vrai elle
était longue mais on a vraiment pu
travailler et expliquer aller dans le
détail et d'ailleurs au fur et à mesure
du temps de la CMP les oppositions
étaient moins en moins virul de voir
plus du tout parce qu'il y avait des
explications qui sont données et en fait
très souvent quand on en parle
rapidement on se on a on parle d'une
mesure et la seule chose qui a imprimé
dans l'opinion publique c'était la
mesure d'âge alors qu'en fait c'est un
effort c'est vrai qu'on demande on
demande de travailler plus comme dans
tous les pays européens autour de nous
on n'a pas on n'a rien inventé on est
plutôt en retard par rapport aux autres
travailler plus pour garantir des
pensions des cotisations suffisantes au
niveau de pension et tout le reste en
fait ce sont des améliorations et toutes
ces améliorations qu'on a portées en
fait on n'a pas réussi à pouvoir le
faire entendre parce que on était bloqué
sur la mesure d'âge est-ce que vous
admettez quand même peut-être un déficit
de pédagogie parce que quand même on a
entendu pendant tout ce débats beaucoup
de ministres beaucoup de de députés de
la majorité dont vous êtes qui disait
c'est une réforme juste et ce qui
n'aurait pas fallu plutôt dire quelque
chose comme c'est une réforme pénible on
va travailler plus mégapale choix etc
est-ce que vous admettez qu'il y a une
erreur de communication ça très forme
moi je juge pas les communications des
uns des autres ce que je sais c'est dans
mon groupe 37 députés ont pris la parole
pendant ces c'est c'est toute cette face
trente est différent on prie la parole
dans les médias nationaux locaux
télévision radio il y a eu une
explication ils ont été là ils ont été
au fond ils ont expliqué et on a
toujours dit une chose c'est tout en
forme d'effort je le redis je l'ai
toujours dit c'est une réforme des fois
on demande un effort aux Français qui le
peuvent pour garantir un niveau de
pension une retraite et pas aux
entreprises pour avoir une retraite
digne pour avoir une retraite digne
alors après il y a une question
politique vous avez raison c'était le
débat qu'on aurait voulu avoir
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que on veut
baisser le chômage oui est-ce que depuis
2017 au moins là-dessus on pourra pas
nous faire le grief on a une politique
très claire oui moins de taxes oui moins
d'impôts moins il y en a d'impôt moins
d'attaque moins d'un cotisations comme
par hasard on a beaucoup moins de
chômage donc pas d'efforts c'est c'est
pas une question d'effort de mandat nous
sommes déjà le pays qui taxe le plus
nous sommes déjà le pays qui allait plus
forte cotisations sommes déjà celui et
le pays qui a les impôts les plus
importants est-ce que ça marche mieux
non il y a un moment il faut être
réaliste regardons ce que fait autour de
nous les Allemands travaillent jusqu'à
67 ans les Espagnols les Italiens soient
entre 65 66 ans c'est déjà le cas si on
veut garder un système par répartition
auquel nous sommes tous attachés il nous
faut travailler plus les Français je le
dis travail moins que les autres ils
travaillent moins que les autres depuis
20 ans nous avons passé l'idée un peu
folle qu'au fond le progrès c'était de
travailler moins ce n'est pas vrai le
monde avance nous ne sommes pas une île
nous avons besoin de travailler plus en
tout cas ceux qui le peuvent doivent
travailler un peu plus nous travaillons
un peu plus et en échange évidemment
ceux qui ne peuvent qu'ils sont usés toi
pouvoir partir plus tôt c'est ce que
nous avons porté dans cette réforme
et bien on va terminer avec cette
première à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
l'homme ailleurs puisque la commission
d'enquête parlementaire visant à établir
la perte de souveraineté énergétique de
la France auditionner en plein en plein
49-3 deux anciens présidents de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy d'abord puis
François Hollande extrait de ses
auditions très suivies quand vous les
politiques vous avez peur du nucléaire
vous envoyez un signal que vous allez
détruire cette filière parce que
attention l'arrêter c'est le détruire
c'est comme si vous m'expliquez
que l'Atlantique l'océan Indien est le
Pacifique il n'y a pas de marée
avec le nucléaire vous avancez vous
reculez vous vivez vous mourrez c'est ça
la filière technologique d'autres
intensité
c'est parce qu'il y a des difficultés
dans la filière nucléaire c'est parce
que précisément elle fait face à un
certain nombre de réparations qui sont
nécessaires ou de vigilance qui doivent
être accrues par rapport à des
incidences c'est parce que la filière
est dans cette situation
que nous devons la défendre et c'est ce
que j'ai fait tout au long de mon mandat
défendre la filière nucléaire tout en
souhaitant voulant travaillant pour que
elle puisse être complétée par une
montée des énergies renouvelables voilà
il y a donc eu ces deux auditions ce
jeudi 16 mars au moment où le 49-3 était
déclenché d'un côté Nicolas Sarkozy qui
s'est posé en art dans défenseur du
nucléaire de l'autre François Hollande
qui lui avait en son époque décidé de
faire mes Fessenheim pour vous qui des
deux présidents a eu la meilleure
stratégie sur le nucléaire
moi j'ai pas envie de donner des points
Intel un tel de faire c'est toujours
très simple de donner son avis quand au
fond on est cinq dix ans après et qui
avait raison qui a tort je pense que hé
l'un et l'autre d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant c'est c'est deux auditions
montré que face à des décisions à
prendre c'était déjà d'abord compliqué
qu'il y avait un contexte national et
international qui rend qui est expliqué
les décisions j'ai trouvé les en tout
cas des extraits que j'ai pu voir les
l'un et l'autre voulant expliquer très
pédagogique utilisez le mot très
pédagogique qui expliquait pourquoi il
prenait tel état j'ai le sentiment avec
sincérité leur sincérité des uns les
autres et qu'on voulait expliquer
d'abord c'est un beau message pour nous
parce que nous sommes en responsabilité
nous devons prendre les mesures pour la
suite pour les 10 15 20 années peut-être
que ce sera à nous qui seront à leur
place dans dans quelques temps pour
expliquer les choix les choix sont
compliqués moi vous savez je suis je
suis un homme d'entreprise qui vient
aussi le secteur technologique
c'est toujours facile de faire les
guerres après ce que je vois c'est à
quel point aussi l'opinion s'est
retournée depuis quelques mois
qui est devenu très pro-nucléaire alors
que il y avait une intention de plutôt
en sortir parce qu'il y a un principe de
réalité oui nous avons besoin
d'électricité nous avons besoin de
beaucoup beaucoup plus d'électricité
dans les années qui viennent et donc il
va falloir produire beaucoup plus on ne
peut pas produire d'hydrogène si on n'a
pas énormément d'électricité par exemple
et donc ça évidemment nous restons sur
le le choc qui a été Fukushima je crois
qu'a profondément marqué chacun d'entre
nous et qu'au fond c'est dit on va
pouvoir vivre avec uniquement du
renouvelable il faut du renouvelable on
l'a on a porté une loi pour accélérer le
renouvelable mais il va falloir du
nucléaire il va falloir plus de
nucléaire sur deux jambes et je crois
que dans l'ordre de sincérité ils ont pu
expliquer des décisions ça nous éclaire
nous aussi soit décision à prendre pour
maintenant et dans l'avenir et donc
Emmanuel Macron finalement a aussi suivi
ce retournement de l'opinion sur le
nucléaire car dans le premier il était
plus sur une trajectoire de réduction du
nucléaire et maintenant il est sur une
trajectoire de relance de l'énergie
nucléaire en bas on va rentrer dans le
détail la filière du nucléaire était en
danger j'entendais les mots de Nicolas
Sarkozy la raison là-dessus au fond dans
l'industrie où vous êtes en avance ou
vous arrêtez il y a pas de milieu il y a
pas de on avait un sentiment qu'au fond
à travers EDF à travers qui était la
tête de fil de la filière nucléaire
française on était plutôt dans un moment
où on allait plutôt démanteler les les
filières nucléaires et que il y avait
plus de stratégie long terme il fallait
remettre une stratégie mais une
stratégie industrielle on n'appuie pas
sur un bouton c'est pas un texte de loi
c'est comment réorganise totalement une
filière on a pu assez ingénieur
nucléaire on a perdu un savoir-faire ça
revient pas comme ça vous savez c'est
comme dans plein d'autres domaines il va
falloir du temps pour le réorganiser
mais s'il n'y a pas de volonté politique
s'il y a pas de volonté industrielle
inscrite dans le long terme ce n'est pas
possible et c'est ça que a fait Emmanuel
Macron remettent de la volonté
industrielle économique retrouver les
financements et une stratégie long terme
allez on va finir en jetant un coup
d'oeil à l'agenda de la semaine
prochaine au Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et conséquence de l'utilisation du 49-3
lundi aura lieu le débat sur une des
motions de censure déposée celle du
groupe liotte les députés du territoire
ce sera 16h et ce mardi les sénateurs
des patrons d'une proposition de loi
pour protéger les enfants victimes de
violence intrafamiliale c'est la fin de
cette émission merci beaucoup Sylvain
Maillard d'y avoir participé et merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi et rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
ciao ciao
[Musique]